ooh
[Music]
vampires oh wait say Lian's again
[Music]
yes folks it is time once again for an
overdue Doctor Who review in this
particular episode of Council of geeks
is being sponsored by dashlane as a top
rated desktop and mobile app that helps
make the irritating and riskier parts of
having an online life a little bit
simpler a little bit safer this includes
a password manager and digital wallet to
easily navigate all your accounts across
the web breach alerts if any of these
accounts are ever compromised dark web
monitoring and even a built in VPN with
country select it works across all
devices and platforms so you no longer
have to worry about saving passwords to
specific devices the app is free to
download and if you follow the link in
the description you'll get dashlane
premium free for 30 days using the code
Council of geeks which will also net you
10% off if you decide to keep the
service so consider giving it a look
either right now or at the other side of
this after I'm done talking about
vampires in Venice an episode that I
have not watched since its original
airing not because it's bad I can
honestly forget it exists and to give
you an idea of to what degree I tend to
forget this thing exists I actually had
to rearrange my schedule because I
completely forgot to put this one on
here when I was working out my my
shooting schedule and my docket
I skipped in a woman right Jaime's
choice yeah so vampires in Venice for as
forgettable as I find this one to be
first of all as I said it's not bad
there's nothing actually all that really
brawn with it it's just got a lot of wow
I was gonna say it's got a lot that
isn't memorable I guess the pithy irwe
just say nothing about it particularly
is it still has some decent stuff in it
I actually especially knowing how things
will develop later on I'm having a lot
of fun on this rewatch paying close
attention to Rory and Amy and actually
I'm
I'm not as down about a me having trying
having tried to jump the doctors bones
as I was when it first happened cuz when
it first happened my initial thought was
oh god here we go again because
obviously Rose was in love with the
doctor and Martha had a massive crush on
him Donna didn't which is why Dunn is
the best it's not the only reason but
it's part of the reason so it really
bummed me out to see kind of coming back
to this but the thing is now that I'm
actually paying more attention and not
just sort of taking it as oh god this
again kind of thing there's a bit more
nuance going on here than I had first
given it credit for now granted the
actual attempt to get along with him
was last episode but we're dealing with
the fallout from that and it's this
episode where it kind of clicked for me
a little bit more the thing is and what
click this is the place was seeing Rory
seeing him at his bachelor party and
seeing how excited he was you know
leaving that message for Amy the
difference between the two of them is
that Rory believes very firmly that
marrying Amy is going to be the most
exciting thing that ever happens to him
whereas Amy is terrified that if she
hasn't already had the most exciting
thing possible happened to her that
getting married means it never will
happen it's not that she doesn't love
Rory or that she does it's not even that
she doesn't want to marry him she she is
haunted by the idea that she's going to
miss out by being tied down whereas he
is thrilled to get married because he's
like this is the best thing ever so
their expectations for their lives are
kind of out of sync while at the same
time she does still feel for him and I'd
like how much emphasis she put on the
fact that she's not in love with the
doctor she did want to get with him but
again that feeds into this whole idea of
she wants to be sure she's experienced
as much as she can but
where she gets married and that just is
another thing on the list of things to
try and experience before it's too late
so while I still don't love that it was
done because I don't think it was
necessary I do think that that vibe is
still there and that pulled towards the
doctor because he represents this wild
adventuring life that she feels she
won't get to have anymore when she's
married that's still there without her
trying to actually have sex with him so
I still don't think it was necessary but
like I said not as down on the concept
at least as I once was why did I spend
so much time talking about Amy and worry
well again that has expansion out from
this episode the episode itself is you
know this episode does have this episode
is very good music the vampires in
Venice track good stuff I like the the
use of the chorus in it it's nice work
from Marigold but other than that mmm
I mean there's just a random smattering
of kind of neat ideas the the library
card gag for the doctor that's kind of
cute I like his reaction to seeing the
vampires in named him running away but
being excited like oh this is Christmas
I love that the dynamic going on between
Amy Rory and the doctor is actually
clicking pretty much right off the bat
so I was impressed at how immediately
that fell into place and Rory displaying
that he's pretty observant like Amy it's
not that amy doesn't think much of him
again she does love him but she
underestimates his capabilities and the
doctor barely know has tends to notice
him but he's got the doctor's number in
a lot of ways especially when he points
out to the doctor you're dangerous
because you make people want to impress
you they do dangerous things because
they think that's what you expect of
them and that's that's pretty solid
observation for somebody who really
doesn't know much
about him and I kind of like that he
took the window the doctor sails by not
saying it's bigger on the inside when he
gets inside the TARDIS but you know I'm
focusing on Amy Rory a little on the
doctor cuz that's what's good because
the three of them together are good huh
the rest of the episode I mean okay
Venice is a it's a perfectly fine
setting it's a fun setting it's a
visually enjoyable setting the notion of
doing vampires in general first of all
it feeds into the oh look this classic
folklore monster oh wait it's aliens a
thing that doctor who does a lot and I
don't care for most of the time so
there's that I do kind of like the
explanation that the reason we can see
the teeth is that even though the person
perception filter is up the the human
brain registers that something is
threatening them and it kind of
integrates the teeth just so that the
human being
registers Oh danger run I kind of like
that as an explanation but I've
mentioned this before you know fish
people I mean I I kind of I wish they
had either devised an alien that fits
better into the vampire motif
I mean maybe bats is a little too
obvious but like fish fish and the CGI
is I mean it's Doctor Who CGI so it's
not exceptionally good and like it's
just it's a pretty generic scheme
they've got going on it's the kind of
thing we've seen over and over and over
again it's go for God's sakes I we've
actually seen this since the third
episode since the show came back their
plan is not that different from the Gelf
you know this this kind of thing has
been done to death and this really adds
no new spin to it
the one other thing that I need to
address because they're really
have almost nothing to say about the
plot of this thing or the specific
action beats I feel like they play very
fast and loose with how bright the Sun
has to be to kill one of these things
because like the one of the the the one
the mommy's boy which is also kind of
dumb and cliche and I really care for he
like a little Sun glint on his face like
and then Amy reflects Sun with a mirror
like okay how is that strong enough to
blow him up but what was shining in his
face a minute ago wasn't like can you
make up your mind you know it's it's
just there but anyways so last episode
when I talked about Tom the angels and
flesh and stone' I kind of went off on
one about the cracks in time and I
believe what I said was that Prisoner
Zero passed through a crack and they
never functioned like that ever again
they function differently after that
yeah yeah that was it well that's not
true then being knowledge as a way to
pass between two different points in
space and time happens here as well and
we actually even get an acknowledgment
here that some of the cracks do that
some of them do something else so I was
wrong in my defense this is the single
most forgettable episode of series 5 so
like I'm sorry but I also feel like it
almost suffices as the review that just
that fact in and of itself but yeah I
still I still will say that they're
having the cracks just do whatever moves
the plot forward and there really isn't
a lot of consistency or rhyme or reason
it is nice to have it acknowledged that
there
all operating the same way so you know
how I'm not gonna retract my annoyance
but I will retract me to the degree the
volume of my annoyance from from the
last review I'll retract that at least
and acknowledge okay they do they do
actually acknowledge this fact so
they're not treating us like idiots they
are saying yes no we no please go with
us and which is more reasonable that's
usually all I ask and I suppose the fact
that I just don't like you know the the
mystery box plotting device first season
art means that I'm I'm only gonna give
it a partial pass but honestly if that's
enough to get you to roll that that's
fine most of the time that's enough to
get me to roll with it maybe the other
thing is the fact that this the them
covering the fact that the cracks work
in different ways happens after the
first story where the crack is behaving
completely differently from the previous
time so it feels more like a like a
retcon fix than a plan thing I don't
know I think I did like sometimes I
worry I try very hard to leave my
frustration with things that either go
on later or my bitterness at narrative
pet peeves at the door but I don't
always succeed and sometimes I hold
things I hold things feats to the fire
for things that I'll give a pass in
other instances stuff I just like better
like don't this is this this is
precisely why I don't do a number or
letter or any kind of rating system at
the end of this because so much this is
arbitrary and if I start laying down
hard rules and hard numbers like this
episode as this value people will start
thinking this precedent and consistency
and there is not and the fact that I
have now just gone on a tangent talking
about a rating system and why I don't
have one which is something I've already
done a full frickin video on I think
that indicates I really have
more to say about this episode vampires
in Venice what did you think about it
you you seen it again recently do you
remember it I barely do just re-watched
it I still barely remember it whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it there's
other stuff down there as well you can
support this channel on patreon even a
dollar a month is a massive help even if
you don't want to do that there's other
stuff to check down there as well
there's my socials a link to the book
that I wrote and things of that nature
click on things check them out or you
also don't have to it'd be awesome but
I'm not gonna tell you what to do
because at the end of the day you're the
council I'm just running the meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
downloading the app and the basic
service are absolutely free and if you
follow the link down in the description
you can get 30 days of dashlane premium
for free
just use the code council of geeks